[Music]
people say you know gee the movie's
really scary because my imagination saw
more of the shark than you actually
showed me well part of that was was
intentional because I wanted I thought I
could scare people with just the ocean
line and and just a mystery of what's
under the murky water but also the
daughter shark wouldn't come out of his
dressing room for months dressroom
happened to be the Atlantic Ocean that
shark was a complete prima donna I mean
the thing never worked the shark broke
down because of mechanical problems
actually beyond our control and I just
went ahead and made the movie anyway
using the ocean as the Nemesis or as at
least as the threat and I think it
cranked up the suspense a lot more the
shark on Jaws works much better on the
universal tour than it ever worked on
Martha's Vineyard when I made jaws and I
think in a sense because the shark
didn't show up the Sharks uh a no-show
saved the movie